let me ask you about Putin
speaking of difficult conversations so
if you sit down if I sit down with
somebody like Vladimir Putin or Vladimir
zielinski
what's the right way to have that
conversation oh man we can talk about
that one we could talk about
somebody more well understood
through history like some like Stalin or
Hitler something like that maybe that's
an easier example to illustrate
had to handle extremely difficult
conversations yeah I mean I can handle
really difficult conversation between
like two people
um leaders of countries though you're
there's so much that you are
representing in that conversation I
guess the thing that would be
interesting to me
would be like what is Vladimir Putin's
interest like what is the genuine
interest that he has in the conflict
because I think finding out like what is
your buy-in or what is your like what is
the driving force keeping you here is
probably the most important thing
um I think first zolensky I think it's a
it's quite a bit more simpler because
he's he's on the defense so it's
defending his country and his people
um for Putin I've heard all sorts of
things uh you know Dugan has his
writings on uh you know like the East
versus the West the collapse of the West
and the face of like all of the
liberalism and the weird LGBT stuff that
they criticize you've got the desire to
like return to this like former Soviet
union-esque thing you've got Putin's
quotes that collapsed the Soviet Union
was the biggest geopolitical disaster
you know of 20th century and I guess
figuring out like what is Putin after
I'm not actually sure I don't know the
answer to that question a lot of people
write about it but you know well there's
a lot of answers to that question
there's a lot of answers that he can
give to that question so say I sit down
with them for three hours and talk about
it
I think
this is a really interesting distinction
because you do do difficult
conversations in the space of ideas but
also in your stream you have I mean
there's a bunch of drama going on
there's there's a human psychology is
laid out uh in its full richness before
you so to me with leaders I think
a part of the conversation has to be
about the human psychology sure
not like a meta conversation but like
really understand what they feel what
they fear who they are as a human being
like as a family man
as a as a person proud of their country
as a person with an ego as a person
who's been affected if not corrupted by
Powers all of us can be and likely are
so all of that that gives context to
then the answers about what do you want
in this war because the answers about
what you want in this war will be
political answers it's a it's like a
game that's being played again with
words and politicians are incredibly
good at playing that game I think the
deeper truth
comes from understanding the human being
from which those words come